brice est sapeur pompier volontaire à
meung-sur-loire depuis un an et demi
pour le jeune homme de 29 ans s'engager
est une évidence dans le civil il est
technicien de maintenance dans une
centrale nucléaire des compétences qui
lui sont utiles dans sa mission
citoyenne je suis parti aussi d'une
équipe d'intervention auprès de mon
travail
donc ça ça m'aide aussi dans ce domaine
là et puis on sait pas du jour au
lendemain on se promène on est sur la
route on tombe face à un accident
et bah si on sait les premiers gestes de
secours et qu'on a été formé pour ont
faim voilà on réagit en conséquence les
pompiers volontaires sont payés 8 euros
de l'heure les horaires sont aléatoires
et le travail ne manque pas
dans le loiret on compte une
intervention toutes les 12 minutes des
conditions qui peuvent être rebutante
pour les candidats qui subissent déjà
une situation économique difficile
on n'est pas en parler de plein emploi
et donc l'emploi se déplacent les gens
se déplacent et forcément en milieu
rural on peine les gens sont pas là en
journée et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
cherche à diversifier nos recrutements
on les cherche aussi à les féminiser on
a un taux de féminisation dans le loiret
qui est supérieur à la moyenne nationale
on est à 10 9%
pour autant c'est insuffisant la
formation pour devenir pompier
volontaire dure une vingtaine de jours à
l'occasion de la sainte barbe les
casernes organise de nombreuses
animations pour encourager le
volontariat l'occasion de rejoindre les
1600 engagés du loiret